Vsauce Merlin here. And I know everything about what, you know,
and think everything I've built a vacation home in your
mind, and I'm lounging by the pool, sipping chocolate milk right now.
And I can prove it with a little magic that amazed TV audiences worldwide,
by having them rub their fingers all over their screens.
It starts with a clock and each of the 12 numbers are arranged.
As you'd expect.
You'll be moving around this clock in a way that's random to me,
you'll know which numbers you choose along the way, but I won't.
How could I, your wherever you are.
And I'm in my mom's basement right
wrong while I am in my mom's basement.
But with the power of my fake wizard beard, no matter what number you choose,
I will know where you are
now. Clear your mind of its usual. Thoughts, memes, pizza,
rolls, energy drinks, and select a number.
It can be any number from one to 12 and only you will
know what it is. Ready? Go pick.
A number.
Got a number. Good. Now I need you to spell your number,
starting at 12 and moving clockwise.
One step for each letter in the word.
If your secret number is seven, then you'd move five steps.
S E V E N.
And land on a five. If you pick a 11 you'd move,
six steps,
E L E V E N.
And land on the six. Hold your finger over the screen,
starting at 12 and count your numbers letters until you're on
your new number. Okay, go ahead.
All right. Now, spell your new number,
moving one position clockwise for each letter in that number.
If you're on the three, then move five spaces.
T H R E E.
If you're on the sixth, then move three spaces.
S I X,
if you run out of spaces and get back to the 12,
just keep going around the same way. Clock's hands move.
Okay.
Did you do it? We're going to do this one more time. Spell it.
Your new number again, and then stop.
I'll give a second to do that.
Okay. Now I have no idea what number you started with,
or the second one you landed on.
Let alone the third number that you landed on after that.
But I do know that you are not on the
two, so I'm going to get rid of that.
And I know that you're not on the four either
or the eight or the 12
as I sit my delicious chocolate milk next to your mind pool.
I can see that you weren't on any of those numbers so we don't need them.
Yay. Let's go one more round.
Spell your new number and skip the empty spaces.
One letter, one position and stop. When you're done.
If you're on the five, you'll move four spaces,
F I V E skipping,
the empty eight space and landing on the 10.
Go ahead.
Are you on the 10? No, no, no.
You are not on the 10. So the 10 is gone.
Your on the three. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You are not on the three.
That's gone to then nine gone or the one
gone your on
the six and you've just witnessed the magic of the
Kruskal count heart hall. The spirit is really getting a cheat.
This has a super tight one second. Let me pull up.
Oh, the troubles of having a beard.
Oh, that's better.
So magician David Copperfield has performed illusions with several different
variations of this trick from using a clock face to
celebrities, to vacation destinations.
He mesmerized audiences in live shows and TV shows with
his predictive power.
But the man who discovered the Kruskal count was mathematician and physicist
Martin Kruskal who took some delight in knowing that it often
confused actual magicians because it wasn't based on any
kind of slight of hand or it was based on math.
So what is actually going on here?
Let's let's dissect what happens in the clock trick.
You're starting at 12 and you have four possible moves numbers
that contain three, four, five,
or six letters. You've got 12 numbers to choose from,
but we only have four possible pathways forward.
And therefore I know no matter what number you choose,
you'll end up on the three, four,
five or six after your first move for your second move.
You'll either move five, four, four, or three,
which means that every single player winds up on either the eight or the nine
notice at no point in the game, can anyone even land on the two, seven,
10, 11, or 12? I know that before we start,
but you probably won't notice it as you play.
And along the way I remind you that these choices are yours and are
totally random to me because reinforcing that randomness
distracts you from thinking about any pattern that you might
be encountering on the third move. If you're on the eight,
you'll move five spaces to the one. If you're on the nine,
you'll move four spaces to the one and that's it.
It's already game over for you and you didn't even know it.
Then the performance really starts. I could take away numbers like two,
four, eight, and 12,
because I know for a fact that you're on the one it's 100%
guaranteed,
but there's a very subtle element to choosing which numbers to
erase. Those four removes numbers have letter values of three, four,
five, and six.
So that subconsciously reinforces that I'm not eliminating some
specific element or pattern,
like just removing all of the possibilities with three letters.
It's spread out among the choices. So to you,
it seems just that much more random. Really.
I can do anything once you're all on the one. I don't have to do anything.
If we just kept playing, you'd all just go from the one to the four.
I could also add in as many rounds as I wanted, because you're all.
Sync at that point, or I can.
Move different numbers to get you to the final.
Number. That's best positioned on camera,
which is probably why Copperfield wanted to land on the six in the center
of the screen. It just looked better on TV. So great.
We figured out the trick kind of,
not exactly.
What is happening here. Put Kruskal discovered was that a counting game.
Like this is really a chain of numbers.
Every new number is a new link in the chain.
And when two chains eventually intersect on the same link,
then they become the same chain from there on out,
knowing that you can appear to predict a highly improbable
result. Even when you don't know where the chain.
Began. Let.
Me show you another example.
The predictive power of cross-culture count is seen most easily with a deck of
cards.
So allow me to show you my wonderful Wiener dogs,
playing cards. I'll shuffle a full wonderful Wiener dogs,
deck of 52 cards and deal out 10.
You need to choose one of these 10 cards. Obviously.
I won't know which one you choose because I recorded this video in the past and
you're watching it in your present, which is my future.
Then you'll proceed to count forward from that card until we
get through the whole deck.
ACEs count as one and face cards count as five and every
other card counts as the numerical value, it displays.
So like nine equals nine. So if you choose to start with card,
number five, that's a queen, which is worth five and you'll go five spaces,
one, two, three, four, five, and land on the ACE,
which is one. So then you'll go one land on a King, which is five one,
two, three, four, five land on a 10, and then you'll go 10.
Got it. And you'll continue this until you can't make a full move.
So if you land on this nine,
you obviously can't go nine spaces.
So this nine would be your final card.
And even though I don't know what car you picked to start,
I'll be able to tell you which card is the last one in your
sequence.
Here's how I'll also choose a number from one to
10. Let's say I pick four, which is a four.
The fourth card will be my first link in the chain,
which Kruskal called a key card and together without telling each
other, because I don't know which card you're starting with.
We're both going to count forward from our respective cards
since I'm starting on the fourth card, which is a,
for all count for spaces to another card, one, two, three,
four, which is a five. And continue until the end.
You'll do the same thing for your mystery card.
And then it's a it's Wiener time. Okay, go ahead. Let's start.
[Inaudible].
Last card in the sequence is that nine,
because so is mine using the Kruskal count?
I can predict what your final card will be without knowing where you started,
because it doesn't really matter at a certain point,
our chains intersected on the same key card and followed
the same path to the end. And this always works.
Doesn't it? No,
it doesn't about one in six of you are already typing a rage
soaked comment about how dumb I am for choosing the wrong number and
jokes on you, buddy, because I knew that would happen.
The cross schools count with a 52 card deck only works about
85% of the time.
And if our final key cards weren't the same,
then you chose one of the numbers that put you on one of the
15% of chains that land me in the fail
category, but the longer our chains go,
the more chances they have to intersect.
So if we played two decks of 52 cards,
the odds of me predicting the right final card for you jumped to
95%, let's just see exactly how this can play out.
I'll shuffle and deal another 10 cards, color code them and Mark each chains.
Key cards. As you can see,
five out of the 10 cards linked up right away on this nine,
and then ended up on this 10,
the fourth and ninth cards linked up on this seven and then met up with the
others on this queen.
But three of the 10 just kind of did their own thing and converged on a second
mini chain, the fifth, eighth,
and 10th cards linked up together on this Jack and ended up on a six.
There are a couple of reasons for this first landing on a couple of nines caused
huge jumps that reduced chain link opportunities.
The more key cards in a sequence,
the more opportunities to overlap with the main chain.
If we played with two or three decks,
our big chain and little chain would be almost certain to converge,
but this game ended up being a weird outlier where the magician had a much
smaller chance of success than they usually would.
That's the way we know that this isn't magic magic works
100% of the time because it's engineered and
manufactured to be successful probability.
Isn't quite as predictable.
There's actually a great interactive version by Alex Friedan and Ravi Montenegro
from the university of Massachusetts mole that you can play online and I'll link
below because I like you. Yeah. This is a fun,
little trick that you can use to mess with your little brother's mind. But
what's the point. The Kruskal count feels like magic,
but is considered a probabilistic paradox.
Technically speaking, it's a vertical one and.
It has real world computational applications in
1978, John Pollard applied it to code,
breaking and developed a Lambda method for catching kangaroos.
Also known as the kangaroo algorithm,
which is a great name for an algorithm.
But to me,
the trick is an incredible illustration of how math can be at
the heart of coincidence.
What are the chances you run into your old gym teacher at the
supermarket?
What are the odds that you end up going to the same college as the bigger
boy who moved away in first grade,
we're all living in different systems at the same time,
some large, some small, some open, some closed.
And every one of our actions is another
link in our own chains.
What we call fate or coincidence may really be the result of a
hidden mathematical master,
pulling the probability puppet strings of our existences together.
At which point we can decide how closely we want to align our
chains from that point on,
which is cool because you probably don't want to go home with your old
gym teacher,
especially since he saw you buy cat food and you don't even
have a cat and as always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].
Do you live in a country? Yes, you do.
Do you want to watch things in a different country? Yeah, of course you do,
but you can't, you are region restricted.
And if you're traveling abroad, but want to watch stuff from your native land,
forget about it, depending on where you are,
you might not even be allowed to watch Vsauce two,
which is the saddest thing humanly possible.
So how are you even seeing this right now? You're using Nord VPN,
thanks to them for sponsoring this video and supporting Vsauce to and
allowing people in countries that literally block YouTube to
watch my videos.
Nord VPN has remote servers all over the world.
So when you connect to one of their servers,
it makes your IP address look like you're in another
country. And regardless of how far the server is,
the speed won't be compromised.
You could even get higher speeds than normal as your ISP. Won't be limiting it.
And therefore you can watch what you want to watch,
what you deserve to watch, which is a win for Liberty.
So to get 70% off in one month free, go to Nord,
vpn.com/vsauce two,
or just use my very fancy coupon code Vsauce
two and access entertainment.
That region restrictions are locking you out.
You can grab the three-year plan and Norton will be giving surprise gifts to
their customers as they're celebrating their eighth birthday this month.
Bye it's just Chile.